if bleeds we can kill it first trailer
out for the predator so there was no way
I was gonna talk about this predator
actually made my list of most
anticipated movies of this year a
combination of having a bit of a
nostalgic love certainly of the original
film one of the property in general and
really liking the output of Shane black
for the most part when it comes to him
both writing and directing weakest thing
I think he done did was Iron Man 3 and I
still like Iron Man 3 that so that's
relative to his other stuff because Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang and the nice guys is even
better so I've been excited for this so
here's the first trailer and it starts
with kids
it starts honestly looking like et or
stranger things and I have to wonder if
that's a marketing call or not it's
weird to me that kids are in this at all
I'm gonna say right now I I do not
believe that the movie is actually what
the trailer made it look like cuz the
trailer made it look like kid finds
thing kid turns things on and it's
basically a remote control for an actual
spaceship that bang crashes I don't
think that's actually what is going on I
think they just were able to cut
together the footage that is in the film
to make it look like that at least I
hope that's not what's going on because
that feels goofy that does not feel like
the return to our rated predator you
know getting really part of it I say
return it's been primarily an r-rated
franchise in any case that that's not
the tone and the vibe that I was
expecting or was really looking forward
to after that there's a couple of
interesting things it's it's a fairly
unknown cast or at least unknown to me
there's a few people I recognize and I
got excited whenever I did recognize
anybody sterling K Brown I love him I
got really excited to see him and
there's a week from Game of Thrones saw
him I keegan-michael key and so you know
there are people that I recognized I was
like oh and but it's very obvious that
this was done on a with a
with a reduced budget overall certainly
a reduced portion of the budget going
towards the caste this is not a film
that is looking to for two big names of
actors to push it they are hoping that
the either the film sells itself or the
name brand is enough to get it over the
hill so moving past the way it started
which again to me is just kind of weird
and honestly it does bring to mind the
we the the subplot with the kid helping
Tony Stark in Iron Man 3 which was an
okay element of that film but I didn't
bone me over so again it's reminding me
of what I currently feel is his weakest
film that he's both written and directed
but anyways so moving on from that there
is sort of a nice feel to some of the
dialogue both in terms of the actual
lines being delivered and the nature of
the banter like there's just a couple of
lines between Starling K Brown and
whatever guys next to him just like he
saw something yeah yeah like that is
what I'm looking for that dynamic that
banter those guys is like yeah we know
what's going on because that's what I
loved in Shane Black's writing so it's
tight stuff like that I'm looking
forward to and it's a tiny moment in
this trailer I understand that but that
still makes me kind of like okay yeah we
don't see a ton of the predator itself
not shocking because it is it is the
first teaser we get an interesting
wrinkle in terms of the woman saying
that she thinks they're their
hybridizing now initially I was like are
you saying they're trying to crossbreed
with humans what then she clarifies that
they're upgrading their tech everywhere
they go now that is at least so far as I
know as far as the movies go cuz I never
really got in heavily into the predator
comic books or whatever so maybe
something like this has been done before
but at least in the films that is a new
addition that they're not just here to
hunt that they're also seeing what we
have technologically that they can take
and adapt and add to their own tech to
make themselves even deadlier that is an
interesting new addition because when I
think the franchise kind of needed that
because at this point it's like well
they're just hunting and you know the
the most the biggest shake-up they were
able to do was to was in predators where
they where their prey was brought to
them and
them coming to us if all they do is hunt
there honestly isn't a lot more places
you can go that so giving them an
additional motivation an additional
reason to be here and doing things and
and it's an in it's an addition that
doesn't contradict what we already know
about the Predators it feels like a
natural addition it doesn't feel like
retconning or rewriting so that adding
is a good indication of how Shane Black
is looking to actually get more out of
this than just his take on predator
anomaly it's a whole bunch of people so
that little bit was promising but
honestly it really just kind of is those
few little bits I said I like some of
the banter and some of the dialogue and
some of the dynamics but the guy we keep
coming back to the guy who's in the the
lie detector thing you know talking to
whoever I'm assuming it's his superior
officer or something like that and like
I'm not loving him I not I mean he's
fine but I he's reading to me like
supporting grunt character not lead and
I'm pretty sure he is gonna end up being
the lead I'm pretty sure I saw a quick
snippet of him like holding the kid that
we saw at the beginning so it's probably
his kid so I'm a little bit nervous
about whether or not he's gonna be able
to carry this film and like I at this
point I can't judge the action because
it because what we get is really quick
snippets and it looks appropriately
hard-hitting but for me what makes or
breaks an action scene is how it flows
how it is edited together and all that
and I can't I can't gauge that from this
teaser yet so I am now slightly nervous
because I'm seeing a couple of things
that make me go hey you don't know about
that but then at the same time I'm
seeing some things that are what I want
out of this film out of this franchise
out in this particular filmmakers take
on this franchise so I'm not without
hope I'm not now like going but I did
have to watch the thing twice to really
you know find the stuff that made me
more hopeful initial watch I just kind
of just kind of stopped that was like
what did I just see cuz it I get it just
didn't feel like the predator and that
might not be a bad thing because
classically it's been treated a bit like
oral franchise where you just give them
new fodder over
over again and if it just feels like
that forever it's going it's gonna end
up even more steel than it already is
so that's not necessarily a bad thing
that it didn't feel like the predator
but that did throw me off and I am I'm
really gonna have my I up for when a
full trailer comes out so that I can
really feel like I can zero in on this
and normally when I say I want a full
trailer that's because I need story
details I don't need story details on
this but I need to get a better feel for
the characters in the action and the
flow of the whole thing because that's
ultimately what's gonna make it break it
for me at least so those are my thoughts
on the first teaser trailer for the
predator have you seen this trailer what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and we'll talk about it there's
all the stuff to do support me on
patreon like subscribe possibly hit that
notification bell I'm hearing from some
people that I'm not showing up in their
feeds as much as I used to so I've been
trying out to plug the Bell but maybe
hit the bell I've also got a podcast in
t-shirts for sale etc etc links for all
that stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you